et les journées du patrimoine ça se fait
avant tout en famille à saint quentin en
yvelines certaines activités ont été
pensés spécialement pour les enfants
mélanie vous en avez noté deux on va
pouvoir découvrir l'histoire grâce à des
énigmes et que ce que propose la
commanderie des templiers de la
villedieu le site a été fondée à la fin
du 12e siècle par un groupe de
chevaliers et c'est même chevalier avait
pour mission de protéger les chrétiens
parti en croisade
alors lors de ces énigmes il y en a pour
tous les âges même pour les plus jeunes
puisque le premier jeu pisté pour les
enfants de 4 ans écoutez donc ya pas
besoin de savoir lire c'est faire partir
de deux de pique ton g et à partir de
photos et puis aura même parcours un
autre parcours pour les enfants à partir
de 8 ans où là il y aura des ennemis
mais des codes et des codes secrets un
cd de couvrir en fait l'origine des
templiers ce qui s'est passé sur ce qui
est épaté surge études et en même temps
il y aura des épreuves
il y aura des jeux preuve de technique
pour les plus jeunes mais aussi pour les
adolescents parce qu'il ya des jeux de
rôle ils seront invités à plonger dans
la vie d'une commanderie au xiiie siècle
et toutes ces animations ont lieu le
week-end de 10h à 18h ces journées du
patrimoine c'est aussi l'occasion de
découvrir des lieux de manière originale
notamment au quartier de cette noire ça
va danser ça va même manifesté de
manière joyeuse et décalée la happy
manif vous attend à 14 heures ou à 16
heures devant le prisme à elancourt à
l'origine à david rolland un chorégraphe
français casque sur la tête comme vous
voyez sur les images allez vous balader
découvrir l'histoire de ce quartier qui
date des années 70 la voie du
chorégraphe va vous donner des
indications à suivre on découvre très
vite qui a
à deux groupes différents qui entendent
des choses différentes parce qu'il
permet déjà que les groupes se croisent
ne fasse pas les mêmes actions que les
actions des groupes se complètent et
voilà ça crée un dialogue en soit entre
deux personnes entre deux groupes
et ça rajoute un peu à cette atmosphère
que j'aime joyeuse en fait j'ai récupéré
des interviews des des architectes sur
madame dès le lendemain format dame des
landes de l'artiste de la main divine
qui est la main qui est derrière le
prisme
alors pour participer à cette
déambulation chorégraphique joyeuse et
décalé n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire
cet appui manif s'adresse à tout le
monde dès l'âge de 8 ans alors jeu de
piste ou manifestation joyeuse et encore
plus de choix à retrouver sur internet
tout le programme des journées du
patrimoine est disponible sur le site
kiosque point ski point fr merci mélanie
nous avoir présenté ses activités